what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and today we have a spider-man plot leak
that a lot of people have sent me and
it is the most detailed plot leak that i
have ever seen
since doing youtube now this caught my
attention because as i mentioned
a few videos ago a couple of insiders
have told me about
a few plot details that are confirmed to
be true
coming up in spider-man no way home i
did a video on what those are i shared
them with you and you can find those
actually in this plot leak but in this
plot leak sense they're actually tied
into the story
now of course with all plot leaks we
take them with a grain of salt but like
i just said
there are some points in this plot leak
that i know are confirmed to be true
now this was posted online apparently by
somebody who works at marvel studios
they claim that they haven't actually
seen the movie but they have
read the script and they say they posted
this because they're tired of waiting
and i think we're all tired of waiting
and if that is true
that kind of indicates that it's sony's
fault to blame for us not getting the
trailer yet which i kind of think
everybody figured anyways so like i said
it's insanely detailed it's incredibly
long so we're just gonna dive into it
it sounds really awesome is it true or
not not sure but there are a lot of true
things in there that i can confirm
and if you like plot leaks and keeping
up to date with the mcu be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
alright this is divided into three acts
and i'm just gonna read it
word for word as it is and at the end
i'll talk about it
the first scene takes place in an
abandoned building somewhere in new york
at night
a group of teenagers is exploring this
abandoned building for a live stream
they're doing
they talk about how the place is
supposedly haunted they eventually
encounter a mysterious figure stumbling
out of the darkness
cladding green armor but injured the
teenagers are scared but they attempt to
mock the figure but they run
as soon as the figure starts walking
towards them the figure is none
other than willem dafoe's green goblin
wearing his armor from the 2002
spider-man movie
but without the helmet an extended
version of the breaking news report from
the ending of far from home plays over
the marvel studios logo then we see a
montage of screens broadcasting the same
video we saw at the ending of far from
home when mysterio exposes peter parker
as spider-man and of course
jk simmons his new version of jay jonah
jameson
spider-man is holding his head in panic
just as he was at the end of far from
home
he looks back at mj and then back at the
screen we then see the reactions of
various people we see flash thompson
drop a snack from his mouth as he's
watching
surprised at the fact that peter parker
is spider-man ned is with his mother
just as shocked spider-man swings away
as people look at him telling mj to meet
him back at queens aunt may frantically
calls him about what's happening
spidey tells her that he'll be home soon
and that they should move away as he
fears there might be a mob that will
attack their home
peter arrives at their apartment
building in queens and they talk about
what to do
calling happy obviously aunt may ned and
mj know that peter is innocent
they also attempt to contact nick fury
but he doesn't answer because he's in
space then there's a joke about nick
ghosting peter back for not answering
his calls and far from home
peter tells aunt may that they may have
time to figure things out since peter
parker was just a normal teenager so not
many people will know where he lives
anyway
but then they just suddenly hear a bunch
of people gathered outside
yelling at them including brad davis and
a few other students from peter's school
who probably led the mob to his home
happy attempts to pick peter and mae up
from their apartment but the people in
front of the apartment building are
getting in his way
peter sees happy outside the window
gesturing for them to get back down
peter quickly changes to his civilian
outfit goes back down with may and
confronts the mob pretending to not know
what the hell is happening
brad davis calls him out that he should
know what's happening since his face was
just broadcast
all over the world happy comes out of
his car and escorts them to the car
inside the car they discuss what to do
happy suggests hiring a lawyer so they
can settle this legally as there's
really nothing else they can do at this
point
mae says she might know someone she
pulls out her phone and starts
contacting a lawyer we cut to a
courthouse
peter is on trial the lawyer is none
other than matt murdock played by
charlie cox
the witness is one of mysterio's
accomplices the court battle gets heated
as the accomplice presents new evidence
showing a more convincing footage of
peter killing mysterio that was not
shown to the public
it's a video that was edited to make it
look like peter shot mysterio at point
blank
they also mentioned that the video has
been examined for any sign of fakery
but none was found matt attempts to
speak back but he was cut off by the
judge and branded guilty
matt tells peter that he'll find a way
to fix this because he knows that peter
is innocent but also subtly implies that
he knows he's also spider-man
this is the last that we see of matt
murdock peter is arrested and he tells
aunt may that he has no choice but to
serve a sentence and assures her that
he'll be fine
we see a shot of peter in a police car
looking out to the crowd as people yell
spider-man is a murderer
peter spends a day in prison being
bullied by other inmates but he wouldn't
fight back
in his cell a tiny portal opens in front
of him and a piece of paper comes out of
it
the paper reads 177a bleaker street
hurry and we've definitely seen that
before but peter escapes through the
barred window by breaking the bars and
crawling out
ned and mj are at mae's house to
accompany her so that she wouldn't be
lonely peter comes in through the window
may ned and mj are surprised and happy
that peter escaped but also concerned as
that would ruin his reputation even
further
peter tells them that doctor strange is
calling for him and he'll be going there
ned and mj asked to go with him he
disagrees but eventually they all go
together
they arrive and look around at the place
and they look up to see dr strange
dramatically floating down the stairs
and this is the picture that was
officially released where tom
zendaya and jacob are looking up he
leads them to a room with an orb in the
middle with vein-like trails all over
the area
he explains that the flow of time has
somehow been disturbed and that many
realities are
starting to bleed into each other and
obviously with loki
we know this to be true strange tells
peter that two timelines are merging
into their own but with the orb that he
apparently dug up from somewhere it has
the ability to slow down the merging
process
peter asked strange why he called on him
and not somebody else and strange says
that he is somehow the center of the
current problem he's dealing with
a problem that's part of an even bigger
problem strain says that he can't leave
the sanctum because he has to keep
reality stable and this is very
difficult now as all the infinity stones
have been destroyed so he has to rely on
pure magic
it is from here that strange starts to
warn peter about the villains and he
reveals that the villains are taken from
various points of the timeline of the
tobey maguire and andrew garfield movies
as timelines
to make sure that peter is up for the
task strange teleports peter's iron
spider suit to the sanctum and combines
it with magic
turning it into an integrated suit he
tells peter that it'll allow him to use
magic that will allow him to put the
villains in stasis and put them back
into the sanctum so strange can bring
them back to their respective universes
and timelines
and peter actually ends up capturing the
villains and bringing them back to the
sanctum but peter was injured
fighting doc ock while recovering peter
talks to sandman
and learns that back in his reality his
daughter penny is sick and that he's
only been doing everything he can to
save her
peter recognizes the name and asks him
if her last name is marco to which he
says
yes peter tells him that he knows a girl
named penny marco in his school
who was happy and was the survivor of
sickness and that her father flint
died during a bank robbery in an attempt
to get money to save her
he reveals that his name is also flint
and sheds a tear
peter then asks him what the peter in
his world is like and he tells him that
he only fought him once
inside an armored vehicle may ends up at
the sanctum as well and
ned mj peter and her spend the night
there suddenly they hear an explosion
where the villains are imprisoned
peter rushes back to where the villains
are and found that most of them have
escaped except for sandman who looks at
him and says sorry before disappearing
strange was caught off guard and injured
by the explosion and says that the event
has worsened the reality state
strange tells peter not to go after them
while injured but of course peter puts
on the integrated suit
and he goes and leaves he ends up
fighting them all except for sandman who
is really trying his best not to hurt
him but the other villains try and kill
him
spider-man ends up crashing into a
rooftop completely battered more than he
ever was before
then a figure and green armor and a
purple hoodie approaches him he takes
off his hood revealing him to be norman
osborne of the sam raimi universe and
here's where things actually start to
get pretty intense we find out that he
was taken from the sam raimi universe
right before the glider ran into him and
killed him but he was actually sent to
the past
of the mcu the main sacred timeline from
there he actually
murdered the current norman osborn
preventing ozcorp from existing
in the mcu instead of turning oscorp
into a big name
he instead waited for the right time to
strike at first he thought the mcu
didn't have a spider-man but later found
out about his existence because of the
events of homecoming and far from home
norman prepares to kill him as he has
learned his lesson not to let spider-man
live and get in his way
but right before he goes to kill him
spider-man is saved by none other than
andrew
garfield spider-man he grabs him and
takes him back to the sanctum
and apparently that's the end of act one
and now we go into act two
back at the sanctum ned mj and aunt may
are surprised to see
another spider-man carrying peter we
find out that andrew spider-man has
actually been in the mcu for a few
months and doctor strange says that he
used a forgotten spell
that's able to pull people from other
universes into the mcu while the breach
can do this as well by random
his spell allows him to specifically
choose people to bring over and he chose
to bring over andrew spider-man for help
meanwhile the sinister six have formed
and they now have a base
sandman wants to actually go back to his
universe but the others state that they
die in their own universes and no longer
have a purpose there they're going to
attack the sanctum
kill strange both spider-man and take
the orb however strange finds this out
as he was spying on them
via astral projection back at the
sanctum the group asks andrew spider-man
a bunch of questions
ned states that they don't look anything
alike but of course we know that they
don't have to because of the loki series
the two of them start to bond and peter
tells the other peter how he went to
space
but then mid-conversation they are
interrupted by strange returning to the
sanctum telling them that they need to
prepare for an attack strange says
that'll help as much as he can but he
can't give spider-man any more of his
magic
from here peter calls happy telling him
that they need better suits
happy heads over to the sanctum but
meanwhile spider-man's reputation is
further damaged after his escape from
prison
and in school flash is actually the one
being bullied for supporting spider-man
happy gets to the sanctum and both
spider-man get new suits tom hall and
spider-man rocking the black and gold
one that we've seen
mj and peter have a moment and they
share a kiss we then cut to new york
city at sunset we see a young woman
being mugged by a thug played by harry
holland tom holland's brother
but the thug is webbed up by toby
maguire spider-man
toby asks if she's okay and then takes a
break at a rooftop nearby
he takes off his mask and then he gets a
call from kristin dunce's mj
it cuts to their living room where she
is caring for their daughter named
may parker they start talking about
toby's decision of retiring as
spider-man as other heroes are now
appearing in his world
toby arrives home plays with his
daughter and then talks with mj
about how he needs to be there more for
his daughter he promises to take it easy
now and we also see
a newspaper that seemingly implies that
the events of the canceled spider-man 4
movie actually happened in the universe
and now on to the final act act 3.
norman osborne approaches the entrance
of the sanctum at midnight knowing that
strange is expecting him he talks about
how this new world is his chance to be
bigger than he was in his other
universe the sinister six start
attacking the sanctum but it is
seemingly empty
then tom holland's peter parker jumps
out of a dark spot and kicks elektro in
the head
then the two spider-man start to fight
the sinister six andrew has a rematch
against the lizard but doctor strange
ends up getting knocked unconscious due
to him being weakened from trying to
bind reality from breaking
this is a huge fight and it ends up with
both the spider-man injured but they
were able to subdue
lizard scorpion vulture and dock tom
attempts to capture norman but norman
catches him off guard and stabs him with
a blade through the shoulder
however sandman betrays norman and
attacks him
sandman is then killed after norman
detonated what seems to be a pumpkin
bomb
filled with fluid as it turned out
norman had a contingency plan in case
the other villains tried to betray him
tom tries to attack him again but then
norman summons a new glider
both the spider-man put up a fight but
ultimately they are no match against him
with both spider-man knocked down and
almost knocked down for good
mj attacks norman osborne with a metal
pipe but
it doesn't hurt him and he turns to her
grabs her by the neck and throws her
across the room
tom screams but is knocked down by
norman with one
punch norman then goes to the room where
strange's body is
and the two of them have a conversation
and norman tells strange that he spent
too much time on trying to maintain
reality that has been severely weakened
norman goes for the kill but strange
lets go of the orb and fights norman but
not before doing a brief spell on the
orb that makes it glow red briefly
norman is no match against strange but
elektro then appears and takes the orb
while strange is distracted
strange attempts to cast a portal in
front of electro as he escapes but
norman grabs strange and throws him
against a wall
when strange gets back up norman and
elektro have disappeared
tom cradles mj who is severely bleeding
mirroring the scene where andrew lost
gwen in the amazing spider-man 2. andrew
takes off his mask
and shock and mj dies ned and may
counsel tom but strains tells them that
they've escaped with the orb however
strange has brought in one last backup
even though it isn't much
andrew's spider-man tells peter how he
lost gwen in his own universe
then peter shares how he lost tony stark
they then talk about how
being spider-man will always lead to
suffering but they must persevere
back in the reemi universe toby's
spider-man is telling a speech to his
daughter
about how he'll think she'll grow up to
be somebody wonderful but then a portal
opens up behind him and mary jane also
walks into the room
the final fight is against the sinister
six and the three spider-man
the fight ends up with norman osborn
attempting to bring back
more versions of the sinister six from
other universes but all three spider-man
gang up on him
the other two spider-man attempt to hold
back the sinister six while tom
spider-man attempts to use the orb to
bring everybody back to their respective
timelines however norman osborne has
been tinkering with it and has damaged
it because
it's overloaded with energy and using it
risks destroying it
portals start to appear in the sky
buildings cars and even people
start falling from them tom's peter
parker successfully sends all the
villains and the other two spider-man
back to their respective timelines
norman is put back in the last second
before he's impaled by his glider
luckily the orb didn't break but it's
heavily cracked peter then thinks about
using the orb to bring
mj back to life and get his secret
identity back strange warns him not to
do that but tom doesn't listen
and he does it anyways the orb then
breaks and peter looks around
as something has happened similar to
when thanos snapped his fingers
doctor strange asks what have you done
and the screen fades to white
we cut to tom in his bed he greets aunt
may good morning and heads to school
at school he sees ned and they see mj
walk past the hallway but she doesn't
recognize them
she also seems more popular than before
peter sees her and becomes
sad seeing her but ned doesn't he just
says that she's out of their league
then tom walks out of a classroom after
class and bumps into a blonde girl they
say sorry to each other and make eye
contact
cut to black while we hear tom ask what
the girl's name is and the movie ends
now as you can see this is just
absolutely
insane and it does actually sound like
what the movie could be
but you'll have to let me know your
thoughts on this i definitely hate the
ending i don't like that mj dies and
then all of a sudden the mcu is altered
to where mj
doesn't know who peter is but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below do you like this do
you not like this do you think this
could be real
let me know your thoughts don't forget
to like the video and subscribe and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof